[Music]
brianna is with us in cincinnati hi
brianna how are you
hi i'm blessed how are y'all better than
i deserve what's up
um i just had a question so i'm 23 um i
have two kids under five
and i want to go back to school i've
been taking some online classes
um
towards like a associate's degree but
i'm ready to actually like put it in
full gear
and get a degree
in economics
so i can
better our life it's just scary
to leave my job that i have now
and pursue that
so i just wanted to we're single
yeah well i'm married but we're
separated so that's a whole another
that's a whole another
uh talk i guess
okay and um what is the goal
career-wise with an economics degree
um well
i think i
it's just like
i want to go to law school so
i was looking at degrees that you know
could give me
other opportunities if i ended up not
wanting to go to law school
but i've always wanted to so
um
so honey i worked at a lot of
i worked at a law school
they'll take you i mean we had students
with literature degrees and psychology
degrees and math degrees and analysts
economics by itself doesn't sound like a
degree that's going to be easy to roll
out of law school with
data analyst yeah absolutely yes
business yes
um
economics
i don't know a lot about that but i
don't think that's as viable as an
option as you think it might be
okay so here what
john john has a phd in higher education
he's worked in universities his whole
life
okay
uh until until just a couple years ago
when he came here
and so um
uh what we're looking for is uh if you
don't go to law school which degree
that could have gotten you into law
school also gets you into a great job if
you choose not to go to law school
that's what he's talking about so right
now any job will get you i mean any
degree will get you into law school so
let's put that on the back burner and go
with what dave's about to talk about
let's get a degree that's that gets you
into a position right to make money
because that's what you're looking at is
how to better your life now how in the
world are you paying for all of this
including feeding these two kids while
you do all of this
yeah so i make 10 and 22 cents an hour
right now um and i'm barely at work
because i'm the only caretaker i so i'm
barely even making any money but i'm on
food stamps of course
i live in public housing so i'm blessed
to that aspect but i really just want to
get out of it you know what i'm saying
get out of poverty my whole family's got
the history i just want to
get out so
i
yes
agreed
and how are you paying for it
college financial aid is covering it
okay so you're going to go
pell grant straight up
yeah but student loans are tempting you
know because of my situation so
they'll guarantee that you stay in
poverty is what they'll do exactly yeah
they don't go away
they don't leave
they stick around forever
until you pay them they're a problem
so pell grants will cover your tuition
correct
yeah they'll cover a bachelor um
so the law school is another story but
yeah
law school you can probably get
scholarship to as a single mother
living on public assistance you're
probably going to find a law school that
wants you and wants to pay for it for
you
that would be a that would be a doable
thing absolutely the goal here what i
don't want you to do is put the cart
before the horse your job is to
you've got a journey ahead of you and
what you really want to do now you've
made this decision to get out of poverty
you want to do it tomorrow
and that's not going to be your journey
your journey is going to be going to
school
fighting every temptation to take out a
loan you have to turn on and pay back
and you're gonna get through it debt
free and you're gonna work and you're
gonna be exhausted
and you're gonna have to call on friends
and family and you're gonna have to meet
people and you're gonna have to ask for
help and you're gonna grind and grind
and grind and then you can end up with a
bachelor's degree that is free and clear
that nobody can ever take away from you
that you don't have a dime on none
it's yours now we're in a position
to if you do this in a way that is um
you know the way we're talking about it
and if you select a degree that lands
you in a type of career
that um
that not only prospers you but that you
enjoy
yeah that's my main concern too so what
i want you to do is just jump on
kingcoleman.com and go through a bunch
of his materials i'll tell you what i'm
going to give you the get clear
assessment
and uh and the ken coleman's new book
coming out uh from paycheck to purpose
i'm going to give you that whole bundle
free kelly i'll pick up and get that all
set up for you now the book won't come
until later because it doesn't come out
until november but we'll send you the
assessment now i want you to take the
assessment tonight
okay and i want you to use that to help
guide you into what you want to study so
that you're studying something that fits
your talents your passions your mission
and um and you're looking at it and
going okay if i was one of those i could
make 80 000 a year and now i'm done with
this poverty crap
yeah and that's if i don't go to law
school so let's plan this out that
you're not going to law school
okay and then if you go to law school
it's gravy on the biscuit that's right
yeah that's true and brianna you are
changing a family system so you know
what you're going to need in your life
you're going to need strong brilliant
women who you can have coffee with who
will be honest with you but who have
managed businesses before who have
graduated college you've walked the road
you're about to walk because you're
heading off into the woods by yourself
because your family the models the
pictures you have don't include this and
their pictures of you don't include it
and so they're not gonna they don't mean
to be mean but there's something about a
family system that'll drag you back down
to their level every time unless you've
got a real breakthrough
group around you
okay so when you go to class i want you
to get involved and i know it's hard you
got two little kids in every minute i
feel weird like you're like you're the
old woman you will provide 23 wisdom and
value for them and vice versa and this
will become your community i'm so
so proud of you yeah this is amazing
thank you you're incredible you're
amazing your kids are going to be
blessed to have walked this journey with
you okay
but find some people find some people
that walk look and talk and are like you
want to be in five years and hang out
with them they will lift you up to there
people who are not there will hold you
down to where they are
okay you become who you hang around with
and
those kids dad needs to put some money
on the table too
yeah well that's that's part of this
little separation here
yeah but good luck with that yeah um
should should that's the
yeah that's a whole other call like it's
my blood pressure boiling yeah i noticed
that and i saw that little thing
happening on your forehead there the
little pump pump yeah
so uh yeah that's but but here's the
thing you're a hero hang on kelly i'll
pick up we'll get you in the uh get
clear assessment take that tonight i'm
gonna furnish it to you free along with
all of ken's goodies and uh bundle on
his new book and everything because
that's what you're exactly where you
need to be
uh
because sometimes
uh folks you you
if no one in your family or your friend
group has ever taken this journey
then you can take the journey wrong
because you don't have a good guide
right
and um
the biggest mistakes
in the student loan debacles that are
out there
in terms of how much debt they go into
and studying stupid unusable degrees
come from first generation college
students
no one in their family ever went to
college before and everybody in the
family wants them to go to college but
nobody knows how to do it wisely that's
exactly right and that that's how you
end up 260 000 in debt with a degree in
left-handed puppetry because all
education is good horse crap right no
it's not
all education is valuable no it's not
not all education has a market value
that is worth what you pay for it
definitely not right some more valuable
than others uh but you know so you got
to get a bit utilitarian about this and
go what is the actual application in the
marketplace
but this that first decision is big and
she's there hey man she's got to do it
right amen bust through girl good for
her you call us anytime you need some
help we're here we're not going anywhere